so as we mentioned there's really been
no shortage of support for the officer
in his family 8 news now reporter Orko
manna has been with us the all night and
joins us now with the latest well Denise
officer Shaima Colonus has been with the
Metro Police Department for four years
but many say the impact he's already had
on the community could last a lifetime
we spoke with close friends here outside
UMC who hope he makes a speedy recovery
my last words to him were to be safe
well wishes for a friend on the front
lines
Lindsey pin FL spoke to Metro Officer
Shaima Colonus just hours before he was
shot Monday night she still can't
believe he's now fighting for his life
this is not what I would have expected
for him this is absolutely horrible
Lindsey and her sister Dana joining this
group that gathered outside UMC Tuesday
evening hoping the power of prayer can
help heal the 29 year old hero sign
showing support and flags flying high
it's tough you don't want to see people
the dirt
tough times this is what we've been
needing to see and unfortunately it's
it's a horrible circumstance ask our
Lord ask God for a miracle save officer
hey James Balderrama brought these
people together to share one singular
message we wounded his family in the and
and Metro PD to know that what happened
there is not representative of our city
the group also greeting the officers
outside UMC some people even delivering
food to the thin blue line the show of
support centered around a dedicated
officer and close friend there's a lot
of people who love you there's a lot of
people who care about you and there's a
lot of people who want you to pull
through
and I and I really hope he does again
Metro police tell us officer Michael
onus is on life support as instant and
is still in critical condition tonight
reporting live from UMC orco mana 8 News
Now